dude I'm gonna get down there and down
under and that's danger area if you
don't know about Australia it really is
a great place to not be alive anymore
they have seven or eight of the world's
most poisonous snakes live in Australia
so think about that all of the poisonous
snakes except for one who must be a real
[ __ ] if you can't even get along with
other poisonous snakes lives in
Australia that's right they have one
snake there the Australian brown snake
he's like the Bill Cosby of snakes this
dude will slip I mean this dude will
[ __ ] you up you know he got just you
know he's just like a long little little
bit of brown quaalude and he just bite
you know he got that that raper bite but
think about that that eight of the nine
world's most poisonous snakes live in
Australia so that means one huh there's
a one snake that must be such a piece of
[ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] that other snakes
cannot get along with him or that he
cannot get along with other snakes and
he had to leave baffling in it
absolutely baffling but they got
everything about the [ __ ] they got and I
mean Australia's that wild place they
got a kangaroo kangaroo sir did the
Muhammad Ali of the animal kingdom are
they fistfight on the Internet
you know see no other animals [ __ ]
fist fighting on Vimeo like you dude
he's King that's Australia right because
you would you don't know a lot of people
don't realize Noah's Ark Noah's Ark came
from England or yeah and landed in
America and and a lot of the animals got
off but some of the animals they've been
you know smoking weed and doing brothel
and you know doing sex down there
selling you know selling a little bit of
that you know that body crotch
and they stayed on the boat so Noah's
Ark went to it went out and went out
again because it didn't have all the fee
the docking fees long term so it hit the
waters again ends up in Australia that's
when all these bootleg animals start
rolling off the thing they got a you
know suddenly you know they'd had an arm
like a hyena and uh you know like a
marmoset had had a baby and that's how
the kangaroo happen and that [ __ ]
hopped right off and started fight
[ __ ] fighting people right at the
dock and then they had other they had
the great white shark that [ __ ] swam
off the back 19 feet long just eating
people just eating people making
sandcastles swimming right up on a beach
and just snacking on children so that's
a wild thing that people don't know them
koalas brah did have you ever seen a
koala bear okay koala bruh all they do
all day at they eating that leaf puppy
they just hide there they are the snoop
dog of the animal kingdom you feel me
then koala bears are there to basically
Data Chief Keef or the animal kingdom
Nimbus is always just snacking on that
green and sometimes they'll have a video
they get so hot I just fall right out
the tree they can't handle it
because their hands their arms get so
much weed in them go play this game with
your friend go play this game is called
chandelier you hang your buddy
you have him hold on to something like a
tire swing or just a piece of rope in
the yard have him keep getting high see
how long he can hold on boy your arms
when you always get too much weed in
them they can't hold anything and that
is just really I mean that's I don't
know if all that's in the Bible what it
should be but yeah man that is Australia
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life will you
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one watches one